I don't think I have to say any anything
in the presence of such distinguished
panelists but I would like to explain
sort of broadly what we're doing
nowadays when anybody wants to fix up
understand they have a political piece
which is sort of what we started off in
the within the morning
they have a security piece we sort of
touched on that they they have a piece
about of reconciliation and dealing with
the Taliban which is what we're going to
do after this but they also have a
regional framework piece and when people
do critiques of what's going going wrong
they generally come down very heavily on
the failure to put together an effective
regional framework which might support
progress in Afghanistan and I suspect
this is what we're going to address now
given the distinguished panelists that
we got together we're going to start off
with the home team which is that Hassan
Abbas and I'm just going to leave it to
to everybody to come in with your with
your contribution to the regional peace
15 minutes each and biting questions at
the end thank you very much it's a great
honor to be here I think we all know
that there's a consensus among
historians analysts security experts
that historically developments within
Afghanistan have been is inextricably
linked with the region especially on one
side Russia on the other side Pakistan
Afghanistan Iran also China increasingly
as well and within this context Pakistan
has been playing a pivotal role in terms
of a country which has huge impact on
Afghanistan and which is in itself
hugely impacted by Afghanistan in these
15 minutes I'll try to answer three
basic questions first
whether Pakistan is ready to accept a
negotiation on which it will have
influence but maybe not full control
secondly how the evolution of Pakistan's
internal situation impacts its upon 11
policy
and last but not the least how situation
in Afghanistan influences situation in
Pakistan the first question straight
away whether Pakistan will accept a
position where it will be able to
influence but not manage not micromanage
or not control negotiations in
Afghanistan for this I would invite you
to think about Pakistan's mindset
especially the mindset of Pakistan's
security establishment which calls all
the shots in this regard and also the
strategic culture within Pakistan my
understanding is that Pakistan yearns
for recognition against for recognition
of its importance of its significance
within the region the WikiLeaks has made
our task a bit easier for instance there
is this one report which was published
one cable which I'll very briefly
mention which said that when Park stands
the army chief General Kayani was here
as part of this member of the strategic
dialogue that was taking place a few
months ago within that meeting they were
sector of defence sector of State
President Obama walked in and Giuliani
was ready with his 12 pager a brief of
which has been published through
WikiLeaks
he started off very clearly right from
the word go he said well our efforts in
Afghanistan meaning Pakistan's efforts
or contribution within Afghanistan is
not recognized
he said Pakistan's fight against
extremists and federally administered
tribal areas is not appreciated he had a
long list of his demands for Pakistan
military he also mentioned about Indian
influence in Afghanistan and it is no
secret even without this leaking
WikiLeaks Revolution we knew this but
the mindset is that Pakistan yearns for
this recognition and they want to be
recognized as a very important player
there two examples I'll provide for this
one is I'll take you back when Pakistan
started off its nuclear weapons program
and also the way they developed it and
the way after the 1998
Apsara Stan wanted that it should be
recognized as a nuclear state that that
is just one example secondly from 2002
to 2003 but Stan has consistently been
saying and this was also a well-known
fact though substantiated by the
WikiLeaks the fact was that Pakistan was
always complaining that they have not
been taken into confidence about what
the US coal and what the u.s. plans are
about Afghanistan and in in cables after
cables and in various negotiations and
conversations the Pakistani leadership
would always say this United States well
we want to be your partners in knowing
what is the actual plan now the problem
was that United States itself was not
aware what the plan was but within
Pakistan it was seen as the day is some
choreographed plan there is some a
larger model which u.s. is pursuing
there is a certain very clear objectives
and we are not taken into confidence so
this is again the mindset that Pakistan
believes that it's a complaints it's
grievances have not been listened to the
second point in this regard is whether
Pakistan would accept a role which role
where it is not completely managing the
situation negotiations in that regard I
think there is now increasing
recognition within the Pakistan's
military infrastructure that peaceful
Afghanistan is a necessity for Pakistan
not only to progress but even to survive
yes these recognitions take time to be
converted into policy it is not that
just one fine morning you realize about
something whether it is about personal
human relationships or whether it's
about policy even when you recognize
that a certain mistake was committed or
whether a certain new direction is
needed it takes time and in countries
like Pakistan where there is dysfunction
between different institutions it is
both obvious so I think yes if Pakistan
is seen or accepted or projected even
within the negotiations as a very
important stakeholder they will play a
role
yes they want to support people like
Haqqani and some other groups but it
also needs to be recognized there they
are fighting many others militant groups
in barge or in Oryx agency in the
federally administered tribal areas I'll
come back to this issue later as well
the second question about how evolution
of the internal situation in Pakistan
influences Pakistan's policy here also I
will again refer you to to the history
my argument is that whenever there was
political instability in Pakistan at
that moment its foreign policy
objectives in its foreign policy
mechanisms were to completely
dysfunctional example again I have in
mind is the nuclear proliferation issues
related to Pakistan Pakistan's
relationship with Libya North Korea and
Iran I would argue there were six
different small there can be six
different small case studies where
Pakistan helped Iran twice twice to
North Korea twice Libya all those six
episodes happened at a time when the
civil military tension was it at speak
when political instability was rising so
the argument is that if there is more
political instability in Pakistan that
the scene making processes will become
become more blurred from 2007 to 2010
the most critical period in in Afghan
policy and in developments within
Afghanistan we saw fall of Musharraf we
saw or observed rise in terrorist
operations within Pakistan and we also
witnessed transition to democracy
whenever transition to democracy takes
place whether in Pakistan or in
Indonesia or in any other country
no one is very clear who's making the
decisions though within Pakistan it's
Pakistan military which which pays the
most significant role when it comes to
decisions about India and Afghanistan at
times of political instability and
tussle a few generals maybe the chief of
army staff and a couple of other people
call all the shots so at this time but I
would argue Pakistan is coming out of
that transition period
we're of course after Musharaf
transition to democracy is taking place
so with the passage of time there is
increasing possibility that Pakistan's
policy towards Afghanistan will be
streamlined more and unlike the previous
decades where it was only between
military and civilians now there are
other important powerful institutions
which are calling the shots
Pakistan's judiciary Pakistan's media so
there's every possibility that if this
transition to democracy survives and if
you want to know anything more about
this political instability and
transition again look at the last three
days of new york times and see what the
US ambassador was saying about political
tehsils within Pakistan now coming to
the last point about impact of
Afghanistan on Pakistan I think it's
huge it is huge in social terms it is
huge in political terms in economic
terms as well but what we often miss in
all of this is that we often look at
parks on strategy toward Afghanistan
from the lens of Pakistan military
whereas a lot changed within the Westone
community which lives in fredley in
tribal areas and parsons northwest were
sons tablespoonful province
those changes those transitions have
played havoc in Pakistan and they is a
civil society response to that as well
the people the passions also mattre
hugely parks Phenom II can call the
shots but there are these civil society
actors there is this public opinion that
also plays a significant role
so in this larger picture there are two
or three things I think that we have
missed in terms of political analysis in
terms of international community which
is that Pakistan's capacity that we
generally believe to be the case
Pakistan's capacity to influence
negotiations in Taliban that is highly
exaggerated I doubt very much and I know
this is controversial point and this is
open for discussion whether really
mullah omar is the one who's calling all
the shots even if he is in Quetta or in
karachi or maybe in Islamabad whether he
is the
one who is leaving this one hierarchical
model where he is calling all the shots
again I refer to this new revolution the
intelligence chief of Afghanistan mr.
soiree or Sally
in 2009 cable he said that the Pakistani
military had reached out to the foreign
intelligence saying this is exactly I'm
quoting from this cable which is very
credible and authentic no one has
challenged that he said path son offered
them that we can help of an government
to negotiate with Mohammed and according
to the Intel Intel his chief of
Afghanistan it was at the u.s. team with
Iran's approached Americans what do you
think about this
it was refused it was this offer was
declined again the point I would argue
even if Pakistan is allowed to play the
role of a bridge builder between quite a
sure or Karachi issue or whatever label
we want to give it whether that will
really make a difference within
Afghanistan I know other speakers have
talked about and will talk about more
about internal divisions in Afghanistan
of the corruption or the lack of
governance or lack of preparation in the
upon military and the police whether
just bringing in mullah omar and two
three four other people and arranging
their meeting with Karzai with resolve
all those issues very unlikely one model
which which we have totally forgotten
about in this context is the model of a
Geneva Accords that was a time in 1989
which Soviet Union's fall was imminent
that was the time when Pakistan's
military led by a military dictator
general zia-ul-haq was absolutely
against having any negotiated deal with
the so former Soviet Union despite that
the Prime Minister of the times mr.
junuh Joe who was a person who was
handpicked by Isaiah he along with his
team his foreign ministry signed Geneva
Accords against the will of General Zia
Huck the argument I am making here is
that if they is a regional model if
United Nations is in war
then there is much more likelihood that
Pakistan will sign on to a peace
proposal to a peace project irrespective
of whether Pakistan military or its
leadership is completely on board or not
um so I I think that is one model we
must look at and through with my 15
minutes I would welcome questions on
these issues later on thank you all
right I might talk about India and
Afghanistan I think most of us
understand that India's activities in
Afghanistan are in significant measure
driving the shenanigans that Pakistan
has been engaging in and which have been
discussed throughout the morning so I'm
going to talk about India and what its
interests are in Afghanistan in the same
way that it's important understand
Pakistan strategic interests think we
also have to understand India strategic
interests and to really get some slit
room to get some sliver of light into
this problem it's probably useful to
also understand how India's how India
conceives of its strategic environment
Raja Mohan has a really interesting way
of framing this he talks about India's
strategic environment as three
concentric circles the first encompasses
India's immediate neighbourhood in which
India seeks primacy and veto power over
all other outside powers including the
United States since I'm measuring India
has been deeply vexed with the United
States over recent years and obviously
it was deeply vexed although quietly
when the Russians invaded Afghanistan in
the second sphere which encompasses the
so called extended neighborhood which
stretched which stretches across Asia
the Indian Ocean liberal India seeks to
be a balancer of influence of other
powers and to prevent those powers from
undercutting India's interests now I
want to talk a little bit about what
this middle range looks like because if
you look at other Indian analysts they
map out a middle ground for India
strategic interests and really capacious
geographical terms when I was doing some
work on the Indian Army looking at US
Army u.s. Indian
armie cooperation a number of analysts
laid it out like this their strategic
backyard stretches from the eastern
literal of Africa going all the way to
the Strait of Malacca to the South it
goes to Antarctica to the north that
includes all of Central Asia and
obviously the Gulf the straight in from
use and they would summarize as view as
they call it the Indian Ocean for a
reason and in the third concentric
circle that Indian strategists identify
it's a global stage and this is where
you see India being very active in
recent years lobbying for a permanent
seat on the UN Security Council India's
had a prominent role one can debate
whether positive or negative at Doha
climate change and increasingly India
seeks the role in managing the global
Commons be it maritime or be a
cyberspace so India is really chomping
at the bit to be seen as others as a
state with power and influence far
beyond that of South Asia and what
you've seen at trying to do certainly
since 2000 but certainly since President
Bush came into power and and saw
creating a strategic relationship with
India is central to US interests India
has been struggling very hard to sort of
cast off the Pakistan albatross and this
is in some ways reciprocate on the US
side by the promulgation of the policy
called D - ization which is that the US
will pursue a relation with India as
well as Pakistan without regard how else
howsoever fanciful that might be to
their security competition so we want to
see India become a global power India
wants to be a global power and for India
to be that it has to be it has to
extract itself from these parochial
conflicts in South Asia yet of course
India has no real strategy to deal with
Pakistan so this this makes a paradox
for India achieving its aims and it also
frustrates and undermines US efforts to
engage South Asia in a way that
consistently put forward our national
security interests so when we talk about
India and of
understand it's important to realize
that it's a part of India's overall
strategy to be seen as an important
player extra regionally but also
globally so in in recent years you will
hear India complaining that it hasn't
had an appropriate seat at the table
that it's been excluded in negotiations
about Afghanistan largely out of concern
or deference to Pakistan's equities so
you'll see India jockeying for greater
influence in Afghanistan and it will
constantly lament it that had always
been excluded from any process of
bringing peace to Afghanistan while
there is absolute certitude that India's
interest in Afghanistan are part of its
extra regional and indeed global
aspirations to have a see the table in
managing international security we also
can't fool ourselves if there's also a
deeply Pakistan specific set of
interests in its activities in
Afghanistan so if we works it I want to
think about any and Afghanistan I think
of generally three objectives and we
kind of sort of quibble about ones that
I've left out or even if they're fair
but the first one goes back to India's
hard core security interests think it's
sometimes easy to forget when we're
talking about Afghanistan that most of
the militant groups which ravaged India
today had their origins in one way or
another in the jihadi production
function they came out of the 1980s in
the camps and Afghanistan and obviously
the active use of those groups by the
ISI is a part of Pakistan management of
its external security concerns so India
is going to be supremely and
pre-eminently interested that
Afghanistan does not again become a safe
haven for terrorist groups operating
against it from the Indian point of view
it has enough to deal with just dealing
with Pakistan is a sanctuary and some of
you may remember the Indian Airlines
hijacking that occurred was it 19
90 december 98 that was an effort to get
masood azhar and other nefarious
associates out of an Indian jail and
when that aircraft finally came to a
land in January of 1999 Massoud is hard
his associates step out of the aircraft
in Kandahar and were transported
compliments of the ISI transportation
services to Pakistan and within months
he appeared actually I think wasn't
within weeks he take that back
appeared in Karachi where he was
announcing the formation of a new group
rifle Mohammed and it was dry Sh'ma hama
is at a december 2001 attacked the
indian parliament setting off the
largest mobilization of military forces
on both sides since the 1990 the 1971
war the difference being is that this
was now taking place in a nuclear
environment so if your india you
understand very clearly that Afghanistan
is not something that you can afford to
be insouciant about even if you have
relatively few instruments at your
disposal to manage that particular
objective the second objective which in
some measure relates closely to the
first is it wants to retain Afghanistan
is a friendly state this is a somewhat
softer version of what Pakistan seeks in
Afghanistan which is a client state or
an extended backyard from which it can
manage other aspects of its external
security policy the third objective is
something that I think very few people
really appreciate and it's even more so
tied to the first and that is the impact
on India's domestic policies coming out
of what happens in Afghanistan so for
those of you that know stuff about India
you have a very unpleasant synergy that
has developed in recent years on the one
hand you have a robust thriving Hindu
nationalism with an increasingly nasty
militant offshoot they are growing in
response synergistically to an evolving
domestic Islamist terrorism problem in
India that has absolutely nothing to do
with Kashmir it has a lot more to do
with how much it sucks
to be a Muslim in India so whenever some
Islamist militant associ of the Indian
Mujahideen blows up something in India
there's always a fear that there's going
to be a responding action by a militant
group associated with a Hindu group and
vice-versa so these two trends are very
much negatively and mutually reinforcing
each other and India has been in
considerable denial about the
domesticated domestication of Islamist
militancy it's no longer about Pakistan
you can take Pakistan out of the
equation and now you have the Indian
Mujahideen and it has its own logic so
when I look at some of the Indian
Mujahideen videos that I have they're
actually strategically outbidding some
of the leftist groups so if you look at
some of the Indian Mujahideen
recruitment literature that's coming out
of the east of India they'll say to
their to their Muslim market yes the
Maoists are right it really does suck to
be you but they're wrong in their
diagnosis because they are a bunch of
atheist coffee rest' we're gonna burn in
hell so they're strategically and
competitively out bidding the leftist to
gap sure the aggregated outrage of some
of these of some of these individuals I
actually had a chance to go to cheetah
camp in Mumbai in April and when you're
cruising around cheetah camp you
generally understand why we're seeing
these the the development of these
pockets of Indian Islamist Mujahid's so
India's very keen in trying to
synthesize all of these regional
concerns yet it's ultimately constrained
but by the fact that it doesn't have a
tremendous number of tools in the box to
achieve these very capacious goals now
India is is not new to Afghanistan I
think when when Pakistan ease and I'm
sympathetic to their claims but when
Pakistan talks about the mushrooming
consulates they they give the impression
that somehow India's presence in
Afghanistan is new and of course that's
not true at all
India signed a friendship treaty with
Afghanistan in 1950 it's during King
Zahir Shah period had hundred
of advisors in fact Pakistan is very
fearful when it looks around and it sees
all of the Indians that are presently in
the Karzai government and a variety of
capacities even though different
organizations might be paying their
check
so Pakistan wants to be sure that there
is not a return to the time of Zahir
Shah when India was was basically in the
back and in Pakistan's narrative running
the show or helping Zahir Shah run a
show in a way that was detrimental to
Pakistan interests during the 1980s
India was you would have thought India
would have been marginalized as
Afghanistan and as Saudi Arabia of
course with us money we're running the
show in Afghanistan but it's actually
surprising during the anti-soviet jihad
India actually expanded its development
activities and this should give you some
sense of the tenacity with which India
views its goals and objectives in
Afghanistan how important they are as
you know after the Soviet jihad ended
and we entered the warlord period at the
same time we had the dissolution of the
Soviet Union all the Central Asian
republics opened up Pakistan Afghanistan
also began jockeying for influence in
that region both of them largely fail
albeit for reasons that were quite
different neither of them managed to
achieve the sort of depth in political
cloud that they wanted to achieve in
that area after the Taliban's
consolidation of power India still did
not let go although the Indian area of
influence was largely localized to
helping the Northern Alliance from the
Pakistan optic what they did was
actually really quite important so they
had a military advisor at the level of
the Brigadier that I met one of the
Indian brigadiers that was the military
that was one of the military advisors to
the Northern Alliance raw also has a
covert aviation wing raw using that
covert aviation wing provided helicopter
and other aviation assistance
maintenance to the Northern Alliance the
Indians did much of this from a base in
Tajikistan Fokker Annies really
difficult to understand what's going on
there because they're reporting on it so
confuse and it's ultimately
contradictory but when Emma Shah Massoud
was blown up in the suicide attack some
of you may or may not know that he was
actually evacuated by helicopter and he
actually died at Fokker ami
so let's go back to 2001 when we were
seeking Musharraf swap eration about the
way in which Afghanistan would be
invaded and how Kabul would eventually
fall Musharraf was adamant that the
Northern Alliance not take Kabul yet
having been at that time at the bland
corporation we were so sucked into
writing articles and papers about
opposed Taliban Afghanistan no one
understood that from Pakistan's point of
view when we let the Northern Alliance
come in it was tantamount to giving
India the keys no one adequately
understood that from Pakistan's Optik
the Northern Alliance was an Indian
proxy
so when Kabul fell thanks the Northern
Alliance it was basically Indian proxies
defeating that of Pakistan and I I think
I have convinced myself over the years
that that was probably one of the most
important strategic errors and a
concatenation of errors that has largely
brought about the Pakistan position on
Afghanistan with which we are trying to
deal today
and in as a matter of fact which make it
almost impossible to change in any
significant way Pakistan is cost-benefit
calculus since 2001 under our security
umbrella who is India like many
countries is a free rider under our
security umbrella India has been able to
establish a number of what it will call
development projects India is very proud
of the large amount of resources it has
put into Afghanistan but some of the
things that India has done have not
actually been all that helpful from the
point of view of regional stability so
globally what Annie has done might have
been helpful for Afghans but in terms of
antagonizing some
regional dynamics that are infinite play
some of these things have been less
helpful in fact I ultimately Karzai is
responsible so for being unable to
manage these relationships more more
appellee one of the most interesting
things of course was building a part of
the Ring Road in the south with the
Border Roads Organization for those of
you who don't know what the border rose
organization is I guess the best
similarity might be to compare it to the
Army Corps of Engineers if you go to
their website they describe themselves
as being a strategic arm of the Indian
Army so the Pakistanis are not crazy
when they say that you know there's an
Indian military presence in Afghanistan
it's especially not crazy when you look
at the fact that this civilian
contractors building the Ring Road under
the border roads organization when they
came under attack
India's response was to bring the
indo-tibetan police force supplemented
with army commandos I know this is I
also met an Indian Brigadier who told me
how they were squeezing in army
commandos under the guise of the
indo-tibetan police force the other
thing that India has done which has been
problematic from Pakistan point of view
is its cooperation with Iran so Iran is
again part of India's larger strategy to
be an extra regional player Iran is
absolutely pivotal to India's ability to
operate in Afghanistan his reason that
Pakistan won't let it through and Iran
is also an important gateway state so
that India can project its influence in
a number of ways into Central Asia they
have a north-south corridor which will
allow India to move Goods up and through
to her on or up and through Iran and
then go to the Caspian and then have
distribution routes elsewhere central to
this has been the building of a port
called Chou Bihar Chabahar is just a few
hundred kilometers along the Makran
coast from the Gwadar port which the
Chinese are building in Pakistan so
remember the logical water port was to
provide the shortest route possible from
Central Asia to the Arabian Sea problem
is only a fool would actually trust that
particular g-locked because for him
who in the hell isn't a Muenster from
quater up through faccia I mean give me
a break
so obviously Chabahar has permanently
unless you're a complete lunatic you
might have a different view but Chabahar
has basically become the shortest route
linking central asia and every other
venue in that in that general vicinity -
in fact the sea so this has been very
frustrating for Pakistan because they
also believe that the Iranians and the
Indians are up to military nonsense in
Chabahar and there's some evidence for
this because they know there's been some
Indian naval activity going on at Java
heart so if your Pakistan says so I like
to say let's put our Pakistani goggles
on so you look to the you look to Iran
and you see a strategic relationship
with India developing that's endured
some pretty crazy stuff and let me
almost put this into context India has
managed excellent relations with the
United States Israel and Iran
simultaneously even against the backdrop
of Iran massively trying to aspire to
the proliferation benchmark set by
Pakistan then you have India's presence
in Afghanistan which you know I've been
talking about the last 10 minutes and he
rehearsed that even in his relationship
with China is slowly but surely changing
as China begins to appreciate and has
begun to appreciate the problems that
Pakistan is internal as well as external
policies pose to to China so if you're
Pakistan your world looks pretty nasty
ER and it gets nastier with every
passing month so when we think about how
Pakistan could be riled up that Karzai
is is giving assistance to a few ethnic
beluche that might blow up some stuff in
Quetta and we say how the world can they
be so incensed about this at so minor
compared to what you do when you put it
from the point of view of the Pakistani
state than the ISI you see it's if it's
a much bigger pitch picture than Karzai
just giving you know some
some roofs and some explosives and using
the NGS in Kandahar to pass that on to
beluche nationalists so in conclusion so
some India like everyone else is sort of
hedging its bets based upon what happens
at first in 2011 and now potentially
2014 and some of the most interesting
debates have actually happened in this
context because India for for so long
had really been in this nerubian pass as
sort of our foreign policy as moral
we're good because we're good well India
is now woken up and has become hardcore
realist capital R and it no longer wants
to be a passive witness to what happens
it wants to be more active in proactive
in managing what's going on it's region
so for the first time you have real live
Indian Hawks that are saying things like
we should send a division of troops to
Afghanistan ok these are they absolutely
unheard of after India got its butt
kicked in Sri Lanka
so the fact even have this discussion is
something that we should really ponder
even if it's asymptotically careening
into zero in terms of probability if the
other extreme you have those who say
Afghanistan is too important to simply
walk away from we should boost our
diplomatic security but let's not being
pussies about it and give our diplomatic
presence some security you know if you
go to kondeh har you'll see this little
puny console they have no security then
at the other extreme you'll have people
who say kind of like many Americans are
saying we're really paying a lot of cost
for this and we're not seeing a benefit
and that we should just get the hell out
when the Americans leave so I'll leave
it like this
um India like every other of the near
and far neighboring Afghanistan are
hedging their bets trying to maximize
what they can get minimize the risk
exposure but ultimately they're coming
up with contingency plans based upon
what they think we will or will not do
another 2011 or 2014
Joshua okay so um kind of need to start
out by distancing myself a little bit
from my name in the program I'm not
actually here representing my employer
in any way so just had to get that out
of the way I know it's kind of weird to
bring up um so I'm gonna be talking
about a region that most people normally
don't even think of when it comes to
discussing Afghanistan and that's the
post-soviet Central Asian states I think
with good reason people tend to focus on
Iran China Pakistan and India when it
comes to understanding where Afghanistan
fits in Central and South Asia but part
of Central and South Asia is actual
Central Asia and so in that context
focusing on these states is important in
a lot of ways because they will have a
role to play kind of just by design by
geography they're going to have some
kind of role in Afghanistan in the
future but not a lot of people first of
all understand the region at all much
less understand that region's
relationship to Afghanistan so I'm gonna
lay out a couple of broad themes without
much detail because there's no time for
it but these I hope at least will help
contextualize how these states are
aligning themselves or not aligning
themselves as it were and then what
those implications might mean moving
forward so one of the first things to
understand with Central Asia and
Afghanistan is that there's a very
significant clash of interests between
the governments of Central Asia and then
all of the other regional players in
Afghanistan I think you would be
hard-pressed to find any official in any
I call them the stands in Kazakhstan
Kyrgyzstan Uzbekistan any of them who
has really strong opinions one way or
another about the ultimate government of
Afghanistan for all intents and purposes
they don't care what they care about is
how events within Afghanistan affect
their own kind of roiling domestic
crises the two countries where this is
the most important right now are
Tajikistan and Uzbekistan both of which
have had decades now of problems
stemming from political dissidence
and Islamic militants teaming up to
create either quasi civil war situation
in Uzbekistan in the Fergana Valley or
an actual civil war in Tajikistan which
killed an ungodly number of people and
then sort of fizzled out in the late 90s
so related to this clash of interests
it's it it's not just that militarism is
a problem or that dissidents or
opposition is a problem there's also a
fundamental economic issue at stake as
well Kyrgyzstan
gets a lot of the attention in this
sense because of the wrangling that
they've had over the manasa airbase
loose Pakistan sometimes comes in for
consideration in this with the cars
ikana baat airbase that they eventually
booted the United States out of but
there are also broader regional economic
and trade issues that well that have a
lot to do with Afghanistan I mean
Christine talked a little bit about how
both Gwadar and Chavez are figuring into
these calculations of moving goods into
and out of Central Asia through these
ports along the southern coast but one
of the most important exports out of
Central Asia is energy and I mean I'm
pretty sure I can speak for people here
like there's absolutely no indication
that anyone is fighting over in
Afghanistan for oil like Christine said
you would have to be insane to think
that that is a reliable way to export
anything of value but what Central Asia
has managed to do Kazakhstan in
particular is to team up with China to
develop non-russian alternatives to
energy exports in a way that has
effectively boxed the United States out
of the region for the last 15 years or
so a conglomeration of American
companies have been trying to build a
pipe called Nabucco which would be
exporting essentially natural gas and
oil underneath the Caspian Sea West from
Kazakhstan and Turkmenistan and it has
completely fizzled out there is almost
no impedance for it anymore even though
some European countries fearing Russian
energy domination have tried to edge in
on it ever since China managed to
complete eastward flowing pipes out of
Kazakhstan the idea of exporting energy
west out of Kazakhstan in Turkmenistan
is almost a dead issue now so what you
see is to a limited extent and this is a
very limited extent because again I
don't see any evidence that
sixteen considers Afghanistan or as a
proxy to that American interests in the
region as an overriding concern but you
see Kazakhstan in particular trying to
balance diplomatic moves by the United
States against much more important to
them at least diplomatic moves from
China and it's turning into a very
interesting and frankly complex balance
of power arrangement in terms of how
people are orienting themselves in the
energy export market and then also in
trade export markets as well so into all
of this mix a kind of at the end of 2008
comes this thing called the northern
distribution network and this is a
series of bilateral transit agreements
that the United States inked with both
the governments of Central Asia and
Russia and Georgia and Turkey and I
think Lithuania and probably some other
transit states to move supplies for the
Afghanistan war from either the Baltic
Sea or from the black sea across Russia
and across Central Asia and into
northern Afghanistan this is essentially
co-opting the old supply lines that the
Soviets used during their war they're
doing this in response to a series of
ongoing attacks against supply convoys
travelling from karachi north into
afghanistan so this is their attempt to
to adopt to a rapidly changing security
environment within northwest Pakistan by
essentially co-opting the Soviet Union's
old supply lines through Central Asia
now this has had several effects
throughout the region
all of which factored into these
countries calculations about how they
consider Afghanistan and how they plan
their relationships with the different
regional stakeholders within related to
Afghanistan the biggest one is I think
at least corruption and this is
something that no one inside Central
Asia actually enjoys talking about very
much but as the ndn has come online as
you've seen this enormous growth in
supplies transiting through Russia in
particular you've also seen a growth in
organized crime and this was already a
problem in particular around Mehnaz
where the entire operations of that base
are essentially run by gangs by crime
lord
the issue of crime in Kyrgyzstan has
already led to the downfall more or less
of two governments it's rapidly
destabilizing the current interim
government over rows otunbayeva and
there's no indication that the United
States is willing to moderate its
reliance on these criminal networks in
order to supply both its bases and to
operate the supply lines and move into
Afghanistan in addition the ndn has also
been an enormous economic boon to the
governor of Balkh province a guy named
normal ha Matata
he there this is something else that no
one really enjoys discussing publicly
because he's not normally associated as
a malign actor in northern Afghanistan
he is not particularly known for
cooperating with anyone that we would
consider to be an outright threat there
however his family has mysteriously
become outrageously wealthy the moment
supplies began moving through termas and
being distributed from missouri sharif
so there is most likely some kind of
flow of corrupt money or corrupt
practices from this alliance of transit
corridors that the united states
negotiated in central asia and into
northern afghanistan kind of flipping
sides so what would what would the
states in central asia kind of fear from
afghanistan they've they're able to
extract a great deal of money both from
the United States China and Russia for
transit agreements but what would they
actually fear from the area
the biggest issue would be internal
revolt or internal dissidents there's a
number of stories I I'm not sure why
there's a cluster of them right now but
in in several magazines and newspapers
there's been an uptick in stories about
Islamism in Tajikistan and there is a
lot of speculation now that this is an
outflow from Taliban militants escaping
the super successful war in Afghanistan
and relocating into Tajikistan and
destabilizing elements there and there's
some there's some evidence that there's
cooperation between militant groups in
these areas but there's absolutely no
evidence whatsoever to support that this
is
and expansion of the talibans area of
influence that these militants operating
in Tajikistan have ambitions even for
anything other than gaining autonomy to
run their old corrupt criminal networks
again but this is a concern around this
time last year
of surprisingly high paced high place US
official actually told me that he was in
his words scared shitless by what's
happening in central to Jai Kisan and he
was saying this because of a single
firefight in which three Taji killed and
about twenty gangsters got killed and I
mean it's it's significant that's a big
deal but there's no reason to assume at
the end of the world that's happening
but because some of these people used to
be associated with Tajikistan's Islamist
parties and because some of them have
purchased opium or transited opium for
criminals who may or may not have had
ties to certain Taliban commanders this
is now evidence of some pan regional
Islamist movement or something I don't
think that's really a fair
characterization of what's going on for
the most part in Tajikistan resistance
carries the rhetoric of Islamism but in
action and even in beliefs of most
individual fighters there's almost no
evidence that these people use Islamism
or use a Taliban like ideology to push
what they do you see a lot of the same
thing in Uzbekistan as well whose backs
are kind of news backs and Chechens are
kind of the boogeyman of Central Asia
whenever you want to talk about someone
scary you either call him a Chechen or
call him an Uzbek and I mean for the use
of X there's a somewhat accurate reason
for doing this one of the more infamous
Islamist networks in the area is the
Islamic movement of Uzbekistan which was
originally organized as a resistance
movement against Islam Karimov 's
government in the mid 90s the challenge
with using these is this canard for
explaining why magical bad things happen
is that they don't really do a whole lot
one of the major groups that groups like
the the Jamestown foundation write about
is these significant global players in
jihad is the Islamic Jihad Union which
is an Alf an offshoot of
Islamic movement of Uzbekistan and near
as I can tell the only thing that they
may have done is set off a bomb in
Tashkent in 2004 and other than that
they're rumored to be headquartered
somewhere in the federally administered
tribal areas of Pakistan occasionally
they're members who are either German or
Turkish citizens who speak Turkish and
none of the local languages are arrested
in places like Germany for doing things
but there's no real tie into these areas
but they still dominate a lot of the
official and policy discussions of
Central Asian militia groups operating
in Afghanistan and in Pakistan and
serving these destabilizing functions
but again there's very little evidence
that they actually do anything beyond
say really mean things on the internet
about Jews and Afghans so I mean in a
lot of ways I guess kind of the theme
that I'm pulling out of this is there's
a lot of fear-mongering about the
negative influences that either Central
Asia can be having on Afghanistan or
that activities and movements within
Afghanistan can be having on Central
Asia but there's no there's no evidence
that this is actually happening on a
level beyond people talking about it and
talk to us how value but it really
doesn't have all that much value at the
end of the day lastly one of the things
that that I want to mention with all of
this is that when when we talk about
these issues and we talk about the
problem that islamic resistance
movements play that different on
politically unpopular trade agreements
pay play or that energy export routes
plan is that they're very structural
almost foundational explanations for why
this happens there's a tendency at least
within the United States foreign policy
community right now at least to wrap
things up in these ideas of ideology and
movements and ideas but when you look at
why these states make the decisions that
they do so when you when you think about
why Kyrgyzstan rejected China's offer to
purchase manasa airbase for three
billion dollars or why they rejected
Russia's offer to purchase manasa
airbase for two billion dollars and
decided instead to go with the United
States's annual I think 180 million
dollar rent there are broader reasons
for that besides either them preferring
American influence to any of these other
people or some kind of Pro Western
ideology or even anti Western
theology behind it um and I'm actually
running out of time to be discussing
this you can see the same thing with
Tajikistan so say Y Rockman's government
doesn't take a more aggressive stance
against these people operating in the
wrost Valley frankly they don't pose
much of a threat to his regime he's very
I mean I think this is a common element
both in India and in Pakistan that
they're they're eager to use American
largesse to fight battles that they want
to fight but ultimately if they don't
have much of a stake in the matter
they're not really going to fight them
to completion I think you see this
definitely in Uzbekistan and in
tajikistan where these governments
essentially abused american gullibility
well I should probably rephrase that if
if if a government official in
Uzbekistan or in Tajikistan screams
Islamism loudly enough they will get
essentially an unlimited blank check to
go address the problem and you see this
pattern repeated all the time almost on
a yearly basis whenever each government
is facing a domestic concern that they
feel they can't face or if they're
facing a cash shortfall because they've
accidentally stolen too much money into
their Swiss bank accounts they
immediately cry out Islamism or you very
conveniently see a bombing go off
somewhere that doesn't affect the
government in any way and doesn't do
anything beyond create a news bite on
the BBC and then suddenly they're
getting checks for millions of dollars
and promises of security assistance from
the United States so I guess I'll leave
kind of that embarrassingly bad picture
what the region was like and we can I
guess talk about it more in questions
thanks Geo we got we got half an hour
and I guess you finally came on to the
common theme that cuts across the the
region we've been looking at the
willingness to decry the Islamic we got
half an hour I think the I think the
format earlier on work best of having
three at a time
anybody want to comfort and come up with
your questions yeah please
yeah Kristen go ahead all right so um I
don't I won't I don't think it's fair to
call it divide and conquer I think
there's this idea that and this is
actually best articulated in a piece
that Ashley tell us wrote in 2005 who is
also the architect of the Indo u.s.
nuclear deal as Ashley lays it out I
think it's point I think it's fair to
reference him because he has really been
the proponent of this and he's you know
very influential in getting these
various policies pushed forward
especially under the Bush administration
the way he laid it out was like this
India has a natural set of aspirations
in the region India and China are
natural competitors and they are so
you'll see India and China necking it
out in Burma you'll see them fighting it
over natural gas and Iran even though
Iran has no LNG capability so fighting
over LNG seems kind of silly so you'll
see India and China competing for
examples they they both want to be small
arms providers so Ashley's argument and
those that buy into it said that by
helping India become the power that it
wants to be and since India has much
more in common in terms of the way it
sees the world and the way it sees its
security threats with the u.s. than
anyone else in the region that India by
virtue of doing what it wants to do will
prevent China from consolidating
hegemony over the region so this isn't
about dividing and conquering it's about
helping India do what India wants to do
best and that is establish its own
source of preeminence and this was why
the indo-us nuclear deal was so
important ambassador blackwell in the
same document that I mentioned they
actually wrote in 2005 says why is it
that China can have intercontinental
ballistic missiles in a robust nuclear
program but we deny India the same and
in that document they even laid out the
logic of helping India's nuclear program
so I don't think it's about divide and
conquer I think it's about helping India
do what India would ordinarily do in a
longer time horizon in ways that
ultimately serve our
purposes you can disagree with that or
agree with it but I don't think the
logic is strictly speaking divide and
conquer and it's also both India and the
United States they have a complex
relationship with China it's it's really
about managing the it's about managing a
strategic competition under uncertainty
really don't really know what China
wants to do we can only see what China
is doing so we can't divine intention
from its military modernization but we
can probably assume that they're not
developed developing capabilities for no
good reason
so it's also about managing the rise of
China in a collectivist way can trouble
you to come up to the mic please and
anybody else is clean you can follow and
opt you to introduce yourself as well
the proponents of the sort of three
argument why we're there what is feel
kinda - is is obviously to stabilize
Pakistan the third one when those to
serve are fall apart the third ones
always did we leave the whole region
will sort of become unstable Afghans it
will become sort of a location for some
a proxy war between various actors in
the region and I guess the question was
from curious to hear is how realistic is
that notion that if we leave the sort of
the whole region will fall apart Afghan
still become too
focal points proxy war and even if that
is a threat what should the u.s. be
doing to prepare against that
possibility well I can address something
part of that in the late 90s um
mullah omar was actually quoted as
saying that he had plans to move the
Taliban movement north from Afghanistan
and to take over the rest of Central
Asia that was originally why he teamed
up with Juma naman Ghani who was the
leader of the IMU at the time in 1998 I
think so I mean in the 90s I think that
was a legitimate concern um I am not
convinced that Omar carries that same
ambition anymore
I assume that and I'm speaking entirely
out of my ass on this but I would assume
that Omar has learned a lesson that
announcing his intent to become a
regional agent of instability is a very
bad thing for his power and for his
influence as far as what Afghanistan
itself would turn into I mean leaving it
as kind of a contested or an
uncontrolled space is bad and it will
carry a lot of effects I think it's up
in the air what that'll actually mean
though my suspicion would be that if
Becca Stan would get over its objection
to American influence really quickly if
that happened if you were to listen to
people like Fred star from size he would
actually say that one of the new reasons
to be in Afghanistan is to pave it so
that we can use Central Asia to transit
goods to the Arabian Sea and have a
grand mercantilist Empire and be
prosperous again so I mean there's
there's a lot of I think you're getting
at something and that there's a great
deal of ambiguity of what actually will
happen or what real justifications are
in that context for staying there but I
mean there's a cop-out but I don't
really have an answer beyond I would
argue that in fact one of the three
things that you mentioned that one of
the objectives is of US presidents there
is to stabilize Pakistan actually that
has not happened and that was not
expected to happen look at the history
of the region since 2001 number one
from Pakistan's internal point of view
Musharaf a military dictated what a new
lease of life secondly the militants in
Pakistan of various kinds
lashkar-e-taiba and jaish-e-mohammed the
those who focus on Kashmir on one site
and a fan Taliban or Pakistani Taliban
specially with the combination getting
support from all the other places from
within Pakistan as a second a militant
reality they got more entrenched they
got more aggressive their logistical
support improved their coordination
their linkages between the Pakistani
militant groups increase so this has not
improved parks instability nor it will I
will also argue that this analysis has
nothing to do with this scenario in the
crannis on today that yes if us leaves
it completely they will be more crisis
but purely from looking from Pakistan's
lens
I think the Pakistani Taliban then will
start moving towards Afghanistan the new
linkages and coordination and new
resources that about Stanny militants
were focused on Kashmir what they have
assumed and acquired in these years will
also see movement of Pakistani militant
groups - again towards fishwheel
possibly so yes if us leaves it now they
will be battle within Afghanistan
between Pakistan and Indian interests
but we can also see that the Indian
intelligence and Pakistani intelligence
they are already fighting in Afghanistan
there are so many attacks taking place
within Kabul and elsewhere where you can
find at least linkages with with the
Pakistani intelligence so the point is
that this argument that u.s. is in
Afghanistan because this in some way
will stabilise Pakistan is and I think
all the evidence proves otherwise I want
to pick up on this briefly so I was in
in Pakistan all summer and one of the so
you all sitting here you know you would
be saying well Pakistan is having its
own internal security challenges it has
Pakistani Taliban boy should be
understanding its primary security
threat is now internal but you would all
be very very wrong because if you are a
Pakistani you believe that every single
attack is actually done by an Indian
agent so even the attack that was done
in Lahore against dr. gun and I was
actually in Lahore when this went down
within the early to hour of the attack
oh maybe it's lust for a jahnvi which of
course it was but by the end of the day
the ISI SIOP campaign had already
filtered out and by the end of the day
everyone believed it was India so here
is actually the perversion and only has
Hassan Abbas right because of what we
didn't have gone asan and how we did it
and the way in which we had the
Pakistani is engaged despite the fact
that they were just as clueless about
Fattah as we were and has spawned a
greater domestic challenge for Pakistan
it actually reinforces their narrative
that their biggest threat is
conventional in India
it actually has not motivated them in
any way shape or form
and those of you who think that the Army
is going to reorient with counter
insurgency pot I would like to know what
you're smoking and please pass them at
dinner because what they have concluded
from this if this is the further
verification of an external threat which
gives ever more justification for the
continued accumulation of a military
buildup against India it is in it's so
detrimental not only between the AfPak
situation but in terms of the entire
regional balance and the way a deeply
dissatisfied anti status quo state with
nuclear weapons is going to deal with
this neighborhood it's not a pretty
picture I just add one point to it
yyy-you warm up can I read this really
tough question by agreeing with risk and
just add that recently there has been
this much transition that I would say
there three major groups in Pakistan and
that the way they interpret what is
happening within Pakistan one group
certainly thinks everything is coming
from India there's no doubt but I think
the support of that group is declining
secondly this group which has now
increasingly think that what is
happening in Pakistan is a product of
Pakistan's own mistakes and renders and
and so many of the inadequacies this
group support is increasing there is a
third group which blames everything or
most of these attacks on blackboard and
on United States the u.s. frankly has
not come to grips with the question of
whether we're serious about this and
that's why we bounce between these
alternatives of committing a hundred
thousand troops plus or going to divide
an option I'd say if we're serious then
let's get serious that's what this
discussion hovers around and if we're
gonna if we're not going to be let's
pull out and then be prepared to pay the
consequences because there will be
consequences to pay so with that let me
invite your speculation about what it
might really mean for the United States
and then all the Alliance implications
that applies to take this region
is what would a global security
architecture will look like and for
examples is to expand on what you were
talking about in the first part about
Indian interests in Afghanistan which in
many ways are fundamentally aligned with
US interest in a general sense how how
would you bring that to bear
what would a global security
architecture look like in 15 seconds go
ahead I think you could actually start
that by looking north ah this year we
have seen the return of Russian troops
to Afghanistan and that's part of this
reset that happened under the Obama
administration was trying to rebuild our
relationship with Russia that had more
or less fallen apart over the war in
Georgia but what you see there by and
large is America abdicating its role at
least in the northern section of this
region what I mentioned earlier about
several Western facing energy routes
essentially falling off the table I
think that's part of it it's hope I
think either close to a year or well
over a year to nominate a an ambassador
to Azerbaijan there had been an empty
slot for a special State Department
representative for Central Asia for I
forgot how long it just was never a
priority for either the bush or the
Obama administration's to take at least
Central Asia itself seriously and when
you take a region that has three states
that can brought comprise the northern
part of a war that you're sinking a
hundred billion dollars a year into when
you just don't take that seriously I
think that might speak towards a larger
issue that the region itself has very
little long terms at least people think
the region has very little long-term
strategic value I would just add very
briefly when you mentioned global
security structure I think all the
various options have been tested though
we are not sure about the intricacies of
details of each of those but in the last
10 years and even previous to that in
the ten years when we left Afghanistan
to its to the region we saw what
happened now US has attempted 10 years
is a long period United States has
really
used all its analysis ordered all its
money whether it was military surge or
it was development money way these
things have been attempted I think that
frankly we must admit most of those are
almost all of those failed I think if
there has to be a global security
formula or structure which there should
be because of Aniston is not a lost
cause by any by it by any stretch of
imagination but for this global security
of structure we need United Nations more
countries what will be the one
consequence of that you will be able to
say to Pakistan or to Central Asia or to
India that this was what was decided
upon any country which they will be
evidence has not abided by the final
decisions of a UN body they the carrots
and sticks should be used you can go for
your sanctions also so there has to be a
global consensus
what is the after all the purpose of
United Nations first of all word but we
would have a problem because India has
pretty much given the middle finger to
several UN Security Council resolutions
as has Israel so I would love a world
that looked like that but I also think
that we are it let me put some it may be
we're just the limits of our national
power given the way in which were
organized when I think about the
problems that are embedded in South Asia
for the military side we obviously have
the seam of the combatant commands and
it first blush this looks like CENTCOM
versus PACOM so if your PACOM you're
dealing with lust retire but throughout
your entire theater be it in India the
Maldives Sri Lanka Nepal Tibet any place
that can go Thailand and I'm not really
exaggerating about those venues and if
your PACOM you see that your interests
are harmed but yet you can't do a damn
thing about it
because the origins of this problem are
in CENTCOM in CENTCOM isn't going to do
anything to piss off Pakistan which will
affect the G LOC so already if you just
think about the same problem but between
the combatant commands but but in
reality is much more complicated than
that because you should also have so
komm involved you schultz have you calm
involved because these groups actually
have roots in europe so when you think
about the way in which our combatant
command structures are set up you
realize that we really have no way of
generally integrating across the global
space in which these these groups are
operating and our interagency project
process has largely failed to deal with
these issues if you think about the
state department we technically now a
three organization of state should be
dealing with South Asia and Central Asia
but the actual gases themselves are
vertically integrated and you don't want
to piss in any one of their bathtubs
because it's it's completely predatory
and can see and concern to be you know
fenced off terrain and what I find
interesting when we look at India so
when India says it's called the Indian
Ocean for a reason what you immediately
realize is that not a single one of our
government agencies has a policy lens
that views the world in the way in which
India does so India has a Luckies policy
it has a Southwest Asia policy it has a
Central Asia policy as an Africa policy
so we have no way within our various
interagency processes to synthesize a
worldview that can replicate how India
sees the world so I don't really
understand how the way in which we are
organized the way we organize our
national security affairs how we can
manage this I will say this much in
shutting up it's great that for the
first time the State Department has
begun a process of a quadrennial review
you know the very fact that the State
Department had never undertaken the
equivalent of the QDR process at the DoD
routinely engages in I think speaks of
volume and then of course the other
issue is is our congressional funding
the way in which we fund what we do we
can talk about a long-term plan to
stabilize a country but in fact we can't
no president no secretary of state can
guarantee that because at the end of the
day it comes down to the vicissitudes of
the Congress and whether or not the
administration
persuade them to do this so maybe we're
simply at the limits of our national
power to do the things that you suggest
and what we're really left with is
basically trying to optimize multiple
objectives well not completely
satisfying any of them maybe this is a
joint optimization problem
Thanks can we take the next question
there's a cluster so hold off on the
answers we're going to gather the
questions introduce yourself please I
sometimes a second-year student see /
you've discussed how when Indian
influence is high in Afghanistan and
Pakistan influence is pretty low and
vice versa
and they're kind of unbalanced at all
times is there a general framework in
which you see that both nation India and
Pakistan would be happy with a scenario
in Afghanistan or do you see that the
inability for both countries to resolve
the conflict in Kashmir as always
albatross - any - disallowing India
Pakistan to agree on any issue anywhere
thank you Thanks
kristinia the your discussion on India
was illuminating my question is is what
do you think the minimum conditions need
to look like in Afghanistan some of the
things you talked about two of the
objectives to their national security
for India related back to Afghanistan so
if that's the case that we're pulling
out would cause regional instability how
do you think we should leave it what are
the minimum objectives do you think we
should we Thanks
hi I'm Priya I'm a second-year student
my question is for US policymakers after
the strategic dialogue that took place
this year what do you think is the
strategy towards Pakistan in terms of
carrots and sticks and is it time for
more stick
I'm a Pakistani and I don't always think
it's India sometimes I think it's bug
boy - serious question it's great that
you guys are here presenting because
there's so many things there's so many
nuances that you could say in fact I
think some people here generally have a
better idea than the common people
people in general why is it that the
perception is it's so like one-sided
it's like it's Pakistan small black and
white why is it that why isn't the
regular public scene
okay everybody gets gets a fighter one
of these not me they didn't ask me
everybody's ready gone gonna start off
the ocean effect I didn't get any
questions about central asia okay think
they can speak more knowledgeably about
indian pakistan many questions about
pakistan as brief as I can be is there
as US strategy for Pakistan what we can
garner from from those strategic
dialogue I'm not sure that the reason is
that it appears that the effort on the
part of us is to continue to engage
Pakistan military you will often hear
senior government officials in u.s.
specially from Pentagon and the military
side saying well a lot of this is
happening because we lost touch with the
Pakistan military 1990s so it appears
more and more incentives and money for
Pakistan Army a lot of diplomacy but
only promises for democracy but
rhetorically we often hear from
President Obama from sacred engine from
elsewhere again I again and again refer
to WikiLeaks because I think those are
very insightful days often mentioned of
this that we want to support our stance
democracy but I have not seen any
concrete significant profound potent
decisions on the part of United States
to support Pakistani democracy frankly
so if the whole effort is to continue to
engage military if that was providing
dividends well and good I hope it will
provide dividends but but I have not
seen any any such thing why Pakistan
image is so poor or pathetic
I also have being a Pakistani American I
sympathize with that point of view but I
think the the kind of problems that
Pakistan has faced primarily and
principally are because of person's own
failures having said that it's hardly
it's just a 60 year old country
it will take time for transition time
and again Pakistan's democratic forces
have regained control people always
yearned for return to democracy we have
seen revival of this active judicial
witch which asked for rule of law we
have seen this media emergence so there
are positive signs as well but at at
present so much is happening in terms of
negative trends negative patterns that
Pakistan just can't help
I personally believe in terms of nuclear
security Pakistan's I genuinely believe
a person's nuclear program is now much
more safe than before and that's where
one of the positive things has happened
that is constantly set by a by the u.s.
summit officials Israel thank you I pick
up on some of the kitchen your issues so
I have to say nothing puts me more to
sleep other than I kveld and the mention
of the word Kashmir in part because it
is it's used as a code word and it has
no flesh on it
so let's first dispel any idea that
Pakistan has any equities in Kashmir I
don't think it does what we can say for
fairly clearly is it since 1947 Pakistan
is involvement in indian-administered
Kashmir has resulted in nothing but
bloodshed and misery for Kashmir ease so
when I taught it lumps this summer it
was very shocking to my Pakistani
students to hear that in fact when you
go to Srinagar the folks there can't
stand you and they can't stand India so
you need to get over the idea that
somehow your your your boys your butch a
or doing anything to help the cause of
Kashmiri is because they're not and I
could dumb break this at length because
what they've done in Kashmir is
appalling and it begins with eroding the
traditional Sufi culture of Kashmir and
supplanting it with this Wahhabist us
that has nothing to do with being
indigenously Muslim and crush me all the
way to more grotesque things like
attacking women in disfiguring them
something that has no place in it isn't
coming from these external majorities
so-called Mujahideen with their their
backers in Pakistan that being said
India is largely responsible if it wants
to claim that these pushin Ares are its
citizens it has an obligation to treat
them like citizens and anyone who is
been to Srinagar would find it very
difficult to say that you would accept
to live like this my interactions with
the Indian security forces in in Kashmir
have been absolutely appalling I'm happy
to talk about that at length if India
wants to put an end to this it needs a
strategy to solve the conflict diad
which is at its disposable it add its
disposal and that is New Delhi and that
is running our and you cannot simply say
this is all due to Pakistan this
absolute rubbish is absolute nonsense
and you need only look at the spread of
the Indian Mujahideen throughout India
to realize this so I think we need to
refrain push Mir that this is really
about New Delhi dealing with its
population in Srinagar and there have
been a number of credible polls at this
point that says Kashmiri is a spy and by
the way there are many Kashmir's there
are many Kashmiri so we're really
talking about the valley there's been
multiple rounds of ethnic cleansing so
folks on the dock have no love for
Pakistan they're more happy being with
India folks in Jammu because of ethnic
cleansing or happy being with India's
what we're really talking about is the
valley of folks that says to hell with
both of you may both of your houses burn
down so we didn't really need to get off
this whole you know this this kashmir
jalopy it's it doesn't take us anywhere
going to this ties into the next issue
which is about afghanistan so barnett
rumen m ed rashid they've they have all
made this argument that Afghanistan can
be solved through schmear III hope my
initial point should tell you though I
think that's also fairly nonsensical but
actually in extrema while at first blush
our interest in Afghanistan resembled
that of India's more than that of
Pakistan they want the place to not be
the home to Sunni militants that
destabilize the region in point of fact
the end state that will help us is not
going to be the end state that India
once now I've made my point clear that
I'm with Biden on this that having a
large counter insurgency footprint makes
us more
upon Pakistan are therefore more
constrained in our ability to think
about new carrots and new sticks so what
might work for us which is some
accommodation with the Taliban is not
going to work for India so at some point
there is gonna be a zero-sum game maybe
what would minimally suffice India is
that if we could it could absolutely
provide some ironclad assurance perhaps
to the use of drones and assisting in
counterterrorism presence that it's not
going to be the Afghanistan of the 1990s
that terrorize India and then quickly
going to carrots and sticks look we have
no paucity of sticks in our legislation
to deal with Pakistan what we have is a
paucity of scrotal fortitude to actually
apply those sticks what we also have
failed to do is to be cognizant of
Pakistan's genuine security equities and
put forward on the table carrots that
are meaningful money is not meaningful
it views it as an entitlement so we
can't buy our way in fact the WikiLeaks
cables have quoted ambassador Patterson
at length saying this what we really
need to understand or what are the
political carrots that might actually
mean something to Pakistan I have been
ridiculed but I stand by it
I think a conditions-based nuclear
civilian nuclear deal should be put on
the table why not because we want to
reward them for proliferating that's
preposterous because the indo-us nuke
deal is taken six years it still hasn't
fructified yet putting it on the table
create space for negotiation with the
Pakistanis
which is simply not possible when they
believe we with the amazing Israel EES
want to bomb their nuclear facilities so
we need to not only develop a thorough
fortitude to apply the sticks which are
already embedded in our legislation but
we also need to create new and creative
carrots that might actually appeal to
the Pakistanis and if in the end they
give us the middle finger and say Janome
shall go to hell then we will have
clarified in our own interagency process
what Pakistan is about and it's not
about oh we're just insecure because of
India and it will clarify in our
interagency process that we need to stop
hoping for the best with respect to
Pakistan and actually start contingency
planning for the reality that I think is
probably waiting for us
Thanks I think yeah we i guess we'll
leave to the next session on how to
rebrand pakistan and thanks everybody i
think we got a five minute break